students of the University of Manchester
in the United Kingdom were trying to
identify this liquid when something very
unexpected happened
oh my god
this is one of the reasons I love
science it just does the most unexpected
things I have no idea what's going on in
this video can someone please explain to
me how this is somehow boiling and
turning into a solid at the same time
over five and a half million views later
it's time to figure out just what this
substance is what these guys have
stumbled across is a very specific
pressure and temperature which
scientists refer to as the triple point
which is the perfect temperature and
pressure at which all three of these
solid liquid and gas phases can exist it
takes just a really tiny change in
temperature or pressure to flick between
one or the other so how did our student
scientist stumble across the triple
point it looks like water in that flask
but actually it's something called
cyclohexane what they're doing here is
actually vacuuming out what we call the
headspace of the flask which is the gas
that is just above the liquid now
because that contains cyclohexane
molecules that have evaporated off the
liquid layer by removing that we're
changing what we call the equilibrium
the system wants to restore this
equilibrium and that means that you get
more and more cyclohexane molecules
evaporating out of solution but it takes
energy to do this and as a result the
remaining cyclohexane drops in
temperature and freezes so the gas at
the top of the flask is pumped out
disturbing the balance and making the
liquid boil by boiling needs energy
which is taken from the liquid making it
freeze then what happens uh helden now
that it's a solid there's no more
boiling and there's hardly any
evaporation and all of the energy is
just conserved but a little bit of heat
gets drawn in from the room which means
the solid turns into a liquid which
means the whole cycle starts again from
solid to liquid to boiling to gas back
to solid the cycle goes on and on
and on and on